Hello and welcome to this video, exercise four, setting up EQS.
So I'm in the engine now, and I'd like you to go to slide five, which is exercise four EQS setup.
And for this, we have a number of different files here, which we are going to be using to set this up.
Let's have a quick look. First of all, we have our three AI.
I'm going to hit play in this case.
And all I'm trying to achieve is when they see me, I want them to run away and find a hiding spot.
And then as I move around, if the environment changes, they will run away or find a new hiding spot where they're away from.
So that's what we're looking to achieve in this EQS.
Now let's have a quick look at our state tree.
Again, this isn't terribly complicated. We have a wanderer around whilst we are just in our idle state.
And then if they see the player, it moves into the flea player.
First thing it's going to do is it's going to find a hiding spot.
And then it's going to go to that hiding spot and then it will stay hidden.
Unless we are the lightest sight, we can see the player.
And then at that point, we'll find a new hiding spot and loop around and carry this off.
It's very straightforward. Again, we are using an evaluator to query the information on the AI.
Now, if we have a quick look at our AI character.
And here we are inside of our AI.
You'll see the main piece of code which is of interest to us is this event find new hiding spot.
What this will do is it will run the environmental query.
We will bind an event. So when it's finished, what it will do is it will get the results.
And from the results, it should only bring up the top 5% or something like that.
But only a very few. It will store one inside of the hide.
So there is a we have the handling, the reception site is the only other piece of code on here.
We've gone over that in detail.
So the main thing that we need to do is set up our query.
And you can see here we have the EQ find hiding spot.
And this is what they're using.
If you open that up, you're going to see that we get a new interface.
And then this interface functions and works a little bit like the old baby trees.
But it only really has a much more limited palette of nodes that we can use.
Now, the first thing that we want to do, drag off this,
and it's going to give us an option only for one thing, and that is the generate.
If you remember, the first step with the EQS is to generate points for us to test.
And we have a number of different options.
I'm not going to go through all of them, but we have factors of class, which means you can select a specific
factor and generate a point on those.
We have a composite, which will allow us to use multiple tests to generate more points.
Current location.
And the ones down here that we have are generating them in a specific pattern around the character.
The donut, cone, circle, path, grid.
I'm going to select grid.
And from the grid, I'm going to increase the size.
So in the details panel, I'm going to change the grid path size to 2000.
We'll leave the spaces at 100.
And I'm going to hit save.
Now, this brings me to our EQS testing port.
I already have one set up with a mesh here that's easy to see so that we can select it quickly.
However, if you want to create one, it is just a question of going into a blueprint class
and search for testing and you'll see that there is an EQS testing port.
So you just need to create a child of this class.
Now I'm going to drag this into the world.
Nice and on the floor.
And so we can see that we have our EQS testing.
Now, we cannot see anything yet.
In order to do that, what I'm going to do is come down into the EQS testing plan
and I'm going to type in EQS.
And this is going to give us the options that are relevant to the environmental query.
The first one is the template that you want to use.
I'll drag in the one that we're using at the moment.
And now we can see it visualized.
Now, at the moment, all of these different spots are a light blue.
That's because we have no tests running.
So all we can see are these light blue spots.
So next up, let's add in some tests.
Now, the first test I'm going to come into, I'm going to do a path finding test.
Because we are looking to find a place to hide,
it's important that we can actually reach that point.
So I'm going to come down and I'm going to add a test.
Down here you'll see that we have a path finding.
I'm going to select that.
And if we select the test, we can see the details in the right hand corner here.
And you can see here we have context, and that is the query.
So it's going to test to see if there is a path between that point and the query.
And I only want to eliminate on this one.
So rather than filter and score, I am going to filter only and I'm going to save.
And now if we have a look, you'll see that all of the spots have turned red.
That's because they're scored, but we haven't actually scored anything on them.
So they all start off as zero.
But you can see inside of this here,
we have blue ones, and it has pathfinding and test zero.
So these have been eliminated from the pathfinding test.
Okay, now for the next test,
I need a new context because we are going to be wanting to test
that we can hide from the play.
And without a context for the player, we're not going to be able to run any of those tests.
So you can see here, I already have a context set up, context player.
And if you wanted to create one of these from scratch, again, it's just blueprint class
and search for context.
And you see that there is an environmental query context and blueprint base.
And that's what we would use as the parent class.
If you open it up, what I've done to do this is I have overwritten the function
provide actor set. And you can see in here what we have
is we have the function starts and the function return node.
What it's expecting is an array of actors.
In this case, I am generating the
I'm grabbing the players and adding them to this array.
But I have also searched for
the BP player standard. So this is a class that I had created
that I've also added to the array. And this is just so that I can test it inside the editor.
Because the player is created at the begin play of the game,
we cannot see this in the editor. So I'm adding in some extra classes
just as a method to allow us to test. Okay, now I'm going to
drag in the player stand in from here.
Having maps standing on the ground. We can use this to see
how it would select points around the player. Let's
jump back into our environmental query. And we're going to do another filter.
This time we're going to do it on a trace. I'm going to select the trips
and I am going to filter only. Again, we just want to
filter because here we are removing all of the spots that the player can see.
And what I'm going to do is I am going to
change the context to the context player and press
save. Now you will see that this has now
eliminated any of the spots that can see the player.
So if I was to move the player behind here, for example, and we looked at it,
drag it to update, it is eliminating all of these spots because they can be
seen by the player. Now I drag this
and do it again. We have a slight problem.
The choice is going to the floor where in this
case we are actually wanting to be testing against eye level.
But in order to fix this, I'm going to come into the EQS flight hiding spot again,
select this and in our generation of points, you can see that there
is a post production vertical offset here. I'm going to change that
to 100 because what we're doing is we're projecting down to the floor
so that we are having the spots off the floor and then the vertical offset is
moving up from the floor. So if we now look, our points are away
all slightly higher. Okay, so that's giving us a trace on location.
So we're not going to be finding any hiding points which the character can see.
Next up, I want to select points which are
away from the player. Now, one of the problems with this is if you select
a point which is behind the player, you might run towards the player in order to get
to them. So we're going to try and select points that are only away
from the player. For this, I'm going to add a dot test.
So this is dot product based on a line. It will
give us an idea of if the spot is facing
the player or not. So with that, I'm only
going to score. So I'm scoring only and I'm going to
do two points and two points down below it. And the first one I'm doing
is query to item and
the second one that I'm doing is layer to
query. Now I'm going to save. Now if we jump in,
you'll see that the points that are
heading away from the player have a higher value.
So if I now drag this player over to here and select the
EQS testing porn, you can see now that the ones so the ones back here
that would probably require us to go towards the player in order to get there
are going to have a lower value than the ones that are away from the player.
And now for my last test, in the moment, you can see that the ones
that are furthest off in the distance are going to be the ones that are selected. So we're always going to be running
off to these far walks to avoid that. So what I will do
is I am going to add a final test in
and this test is going to be a distance test. So
again, this is score only and I'm going to
change the scoring to inverse and linear. We're going to have a look and see what that
does to it. So now if I move, that's going to give
us a slightly better one and we can change the weightings of these. So
the distance I might want to make the scoring factor maybe two. Save
and now you can see that these spots here are probably some of the higher ones
these spots. Those are good hiding spots, I feel. And it's eliminating
the ones over in this direction, which is good because these ones would require us to walk
towards the player. OK, so now I am going to give this
a test so you can see when they see us, they ran away and they find a hide
spot. And then after
I've seen them, they ran away again and again, they're going to flee to a good hiding
spot. Now you can see that one in the far corner.
I don't have a line of sight on him, but he's hiding in a very bad location. That is not a
good hiding spot. And that's what we're going to try and fix in the next video
by creating some custom generation of plots. As you can see here,
they will flee and find hiding spots quite effectively. Well, that brings us
to the end of that video of setting up our EQS.
Thank you very much.